[Música]
más de un año ha pasado desde el inicio
de la invasión de Rusia a Ucrania en el
debate de France 24 hemos analizado un
año después la perspectiva ucraniana del
conflicto la mirada rusa por supuesto y
la posición de otros países que están de
alguna forma involucrados como por
ejemplo Turquía ahora debemos hacer
análisis de otro actor muy importante un
año después vale la pena ver cómo está
la organización del Atlántico Norte La
otan que está compuesta por varios
países y ha dado una respuesta y total
respaldo militar a Ucrania después del
inicio de esta invasión justamente le
posible ingreso de Ucrania a dicha
organización fue uno de los tantos
argumentos que dio Rusia para justificar
esta invasión del este de Ucrania para
el kremlin que la otan llegara hasta sus
fronteras es una amenaza repasemos
algunos hechos recientes que vamos a
analizar a lo largo del programa un poco
por marcar la agenda de lo que vamos a
conversar el día de hoy pues la otan ha
sido la forma de canalizar digámoslo así
la ayuda militar que ha aportado tanto
Estados Unidos como la Unión Europea
para Ucrania poder hacer frente a la
invasión rusa hay una larga negociación
también con Turquía por la incorporación
de dos países Suecia y Finlandia este
último ya fue aprobado su ingreso Está
avanzando en este proceso Y eso
significa 1200 kilómetros de frontera
que la otan va a tener mirando frente a
frente a la federación de Rusia esta
invasión de Rusia a Ucrania ha
revitalizado así lo dicen algunos
analistas ahora lo veremos si es cierto
a revitalizado a esta Alianza atlántica
ha mejorado su compleja imagen a nivel
internacional pues lo vamos a ver se lo
vamos a preguntar a los que conocen en
detalle pero a la alianza también le
preocupa ese despliegue de armamento
nuclear en belarus armamento nuclear
Ruso y también el discurso de Rusia en
el que siempre deja sobre la mesa La
amenaza nuclear desde el otro lado de la
cara de la moneda desde el lado ruso
pues para ver las dos caras de esta
situación el kremlin ha criticado en
reiteradas ocasiones las fases de
expansión de la otan a lo largo de los
últimos años cuando por ejemplo cuando
se incorporaron algunos países que
pertenecían al antiguo Pacto de Varsovia
y también cuando se incorporaron los
tres estados bálticos Estonia letonia y
lituania que recordemos hacían parte de
la unión soviética desde el kremlin
critican también la ayuda que le han
dado a Ucrania hasta el momento ese
aporte militar y de tecnología Y acusan
a esta organización de querer conformar
un eje mundial pero no dicen nada con
respecto a el ingreso de Finlandia país
con el que van a tener una frontera pues
compartida entre Finlandia que es país
próximo a ser parte de la otan y Rusia
qué ha significado entonces para la otan
Este primer año de guerra en Ucrania o
este año de Invasión en Ucrania Cómo
toma la alianza lo dicho por el gobierno
ruso sobre este conflicto al afirmar que
se preparan para un conflicto largo y
prolongado en el tiempo como reciben
estos los países integrantes de la Qué
futuro tiene este conjunto de países en
términos militares pensando en el futuro
y también como interpreta el envío de
Arsenal nuclear ruso a belarus hoy en el
debate el actor importante que nos
faltaba de todo este análisis en la
guerra en Ucrania la otan y su nuevo
peso político para analizar el tema
hemos invitado a reinaldo Ortega él es
analista y especialista en relaciones
internacionales se conecta desde la
Ciudad de México desde viña del mar se
conecta a Fernando Wilson él es analista
de seguridad y también docente de la
universidad Adolfo Ibáñez y aquí en el
estudio de France 24 nos acompaña
Catalina Miranda Aguirre ya es experta
en temas de defensa y de seguridad
nuestros televidentes ustedes lo saben
hacen parte también de este debate de
esta conversación ustedes pueden dejar
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales ustedes ya lo
saben estamos en Twitter estamos en
Facebook e Instagram nos encuentran como
arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios es numeral el debate
f-24 y a mí me encuentran en Twitter
como arroba santilogo no olviden también
que todos los contenidos de nuestro
programa están disponibles en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
bueno comienzo entonces dándole la
bienvenida a reinaldo en México reinaldo
gracias por estar con nosotros y bueno
qué balance hace usted de lo que ha
significado el papel de la otan a lo
largo de este año de invasión de Rusia
al este de Ucrania bienvenido
Muchas gracias sin duda
este año ha sido fundamental para la
función de la otan en términos de su
fortalecimiento como una alianza
encabezada por los Estados Unidos y en
la cual
pues la guerra en Ucrania ha implicado
que su misión fundamental en este
momento está siendo la seguridad europea
la otan está viviendo un cambio
fundamental sobre todo a raíz de una
situación
internacional que ha cambiado
de de un mundo unipolar podríamos
argumentar a un mundo multipolar en
donde
tanto china como Rusia están reclamando
una posición
nueva en el escenario internacional
entonces
y la otra no ha jugado un papel
fundamental en este caso en esta Alianza
entre Europa y Estados Unidos es la
primera pregunta El Punto de partida
para reinaldo Ortega profesor
investigador del centro de estudios
internacionales del colegio de México
ahora le doy la palabra a Fernando
Wilson en la ciudad de Viña del Mar allí
en la costa del Pacífico en Chile
Fernando bienvenido la misma pregunta
como Punto de partida un año de haber
comenzado esta invasión que balance hace
usted de lo que ha significado el papel
de la otan
en términos generales la otan recupera
su función primaria como era la defensa
de Europa recordemos que es creada en
1948 para proveer el paraguas nuclear
norteamericano Las Naciones europeas que
habían fracasado en rearticular una
estructura de defensa la Western
european Union frente a la unión
soviética en ese sentido tras el fin de
la Guerra Fría lotan queda como una
organización excedentaria un tanto
peculiar se la utiliza en para
administrar distintos compromisos
multinacionales En iracas Afganistán
pero no al que particularmente
Afganistán pero nunca alcanza a
redondear una nueva legitimidad Hasta
que el viejo adversario digamos ahora
bajo la forma de la federación rusa
vuelve a aparecer en términos de ser un
actor desafiante en términos de
digamos presentar un desafío estratégico
primario podemos discutir si es que la
estrategia de ampliarse hacia el este
fue correcto o no
del partido es claramente
imperfectamente inútil considerando Ya
el año de conflicto que se desarrolla en
relación a la invasión rusa Ucrania y
para terminar esta primera ronda le doy
la palabra Catalina aquí en el estudio
de France 24 Catalina Gracias por estar
con nosotros también bienvenida y su
opinión sobre este primer año Santiago
Gracias a ti a frans 24 por esta
invitación primero y yo lo primero que
quiero decir es que y por no querer
hacer un juicio de valores que esta
estrategia o la estrategia que ha
implementado la otan en más de un año de
la invasión de Ucrania por parte de los
rusos ha sido exitosa y lo primero que
quiero decir es que es una gran
estrategia que tiene dos vertientes la
primera es no involucrarse directamente
en el conflicto es decir no movilizar
tropas por medios terrestres para no
involucrarse directamente con tropas
rusas en territorio ucraniano pero al
mismo tiempo aportar gran Arsenal
militar Y también contribuir con
sanciones económi y crear un cierto
consenso internacional en torno a
reprochar lo que Rusia está haciendo en
territorio ucraniano y el soporte
militar Sin lugar a dudas podemos decir
que ha sido exitoso en el momento porque
ha logrado contrarrestar la avanzada
rusa sobre todo hacia el centro y hacia
el norte del territorio pero también ha
logrado que a través de esta tecnología
militar que ha sido otorgada por
occidente se logre que las tropas
ucranianas logren replegar a las tropas
rusas en territorio ucraniano y las
sanciones económicas sólo para dar un un
una simple opinión pues han hecho que
Rusia que Rusia se habilita de forma tal
que Su economía se ha visto deteriorada
significativamente a tal punto que está
dependiendo en gran medida de China
china una economía que es diez veces más
grande que la rusa esto no le conviene a
ningún a ningún país en el mundo
Catalina continuó con usted para hacer
la ronda a la inversa y quiero que
vayamos unos cuantos años atrás y
retomemos algunos escenarios para
traerlos al presente y entender la
situación un año después del inicio de
esta invasión y son algunos de los
argumentos que ha dado Rusia para
entender un poco la posición que tiene
Rusia en todo este conflicto a lo largo
de todos estos años hemos visto como
desde el kremlin hacían estos llamados
de atención a la otan de no se expandan
hacia el este no incorporen países que
eran parte del Antiguo Pacto de Varsovia
poco a poco se fueron incorporando
varios países
sí incumplió la otan los compromisos que
había adquirido con Rusia en ese momento
que nos llevan al escenario de conflicto
en el que estamos hoy en día yo creo que
no y yo creo que porque Más allá del
incumplimiento no de lo que la votan
promete o no hacia su relación con Rusia
es el sentir del pueblo ucraniano de
sentirse más representado con los
valores de la Unión Europea que con los
valores que son heredados de la
disolución de la unión soviética Y
nuevamente tenemos el punto de que si
esto es verdad y si estos acuerdos se
han incumplido entonces fin porque va a
entrar a ser parte de la otan teniendo
una frontera tan extensa con Rusia
entonces para mí las respuestas no y
para mí la la el argumento más válido en
este sentido sería Cuál es el sentir que
yo creo que democráticamente se ha
expresado del pueblo ucraniano frente a
pertenecer al bloque occidental
siendo parte de la Unión Europea hay un
punto ahí para Añadir reinaldo le hago
la misma pregunta A usted le parece que
ha habido algunos puntos en los que la
otan no cumplió con acuerdos con el
kremlin y bueno entendemos el caso de
Finlandia que ya lo vamos a analizar
pero Finlandia no es un país de
influencia
geopolítica de Rusia Ucrania y
históricamente ha estado
enlazado con Rusia y con Moscú a lo
largo de muchos años siglos hay que
decir reinaldo su opinión
bueno es que la situación es Es más
compleja
yo lo llevaría por lo menos
a pues desde el final de la de lo que se
llamó la Guerra Fría en términos de
cuáles eran los acuerdos este lo que lo
que ha ocurrido es que ese final de la
Guerra Fría implicó una situación de
unipolaridad es decir Estados Unidos
tenía como la gran potencia no solo
militar sino económica tecnológica
científica
la una capacidad muy superior al resto
de las potencias
esta situación de unipolaridad
significó nuevos retos al sistema
internacional no nuevos retos y varios
analistas argumentarían que hasta una
sobreexpansión de Estados Unidos de
Estados Unidos no solamente va a
intervenir en Europa sino en Afganistán
en Irán etcétera entonces hay hay toda
una una situación ahí de geopolítica
distinta y luego en el caso particular
de lo que está ocurriendo en la guerra
en Ucrania
nos concentramos Generalmente en el
estallido de la de la operación rusa
sobre Ucrania pero el problema llevaba
mucho tiempo
a más desde el 2014 por lo menos y ahí
Europa y sus instituciones no fueron
capaces de
garantizar la seguridad ni de ni de
tampoco lograr un acuerdo con lo que era
en ese momento ya una expansión de Rusia
entonces hay hay una historia que hace
que hace complejo el el asunto y claro
esta historia ha significado y la
expansión rusa hacia Ucrania ha
significado pues la respuesta de países
que se sienten amenazados como Finlandia
Suecia los países del este Y entonces en
esos en esos términos es que se puede
explicar la nueva integración de
Finlandia a la otan el el intento de
Suecia por ingresar etcétera entonces
sin entender esa historia es es muy
difícil simplemente decir Ah bueno es
que después de un año de Invasión pues
es muy normal todo lo que está pasando
No no es exactamente así no por eso
estamos preguntando si hubo si hubo una
falta por parte de la otan en cuanto a
esos acuerdos Y esos pactos que se
habían dicho de manera oficial o
implícita entre las partes y que nos
lleva al escenario de hoy en día paso a
darle la palabra Fernando para cerrar
esta esta segunda ronda su opinión sobre
este tema
no a ver en primer lugar nunca hubo un
acuerdo formal en ese sentido sino que
fueron principios de alguna manera o
acuerdos sobreentendidos en los cuales
lo dan no se expandiría hacia el este
sin embargo esto chocó con la voluntad
de los pueblos de los estados del este
los cuales unilateralmente comenzaron a
pedir integración al otan los tres
países bálticos parte de antigua de la
unión soviética lo pidieron muy
tempranamente En ese sentido Finlandia
que también fue parte del imperio ruso
se independizó logró defender su
independencia después de dos invasiones
salvajes en la famosa guerra invierno de
1940 y posteriormente la guerra a
continuación
claramente demuestra que un acuerdo de
lotan no puede ir por encima de
los nueve de bucarestes digamos todo el
conjunto de estados que componían
antiguamente el el Pacto de Varsovia que
ahora claramente se sienten más
alineados con occidente y por lo demás
Aunque Incluso si esa promesa hubiese
sido explícita
y occidente lo da en Estados Unidos
hubiesen estado dispuestos a honrarla y
finandizar valga la ironía congelar al
este de Europa han pasado a estas
alturas del partido más de 30 años del
fin de la Guerra Fría por lo tanto
difícilmente uno puede pretender que
Rusia la federación rusa un estado nuevo
considerablemente menos poderoso que lo
que fue la unión soviética pueda
pretender dictar los procesos y los
procedimientos políticos de todo una
región como es el este de Europa
sin considerar la opinión de los propios
países afectados Me parece que eso
claramente es una exageración en el
sentido de otorgarle a Rusia un exceso
de poder eh tiendo a creer que esto y
concuerdo plenamente con lo que
planteaban los dos expositores
anteriores digamos esto es un conflicto
que viene desarrollándose cuando menos
desde el 2014 cuando se lleva a cabo el
golpe de mano sobre crimea y parte del
Don vas y que está mucho más vinculado a
la visión geopolítica rusa clási
en la cual la construcción de fronteras
defendibles digamos y de Estados tapón
que se paren al ginterlando al corazón
de Rusia de Europa occidental tiene un
rol mucho más relevante que promesas o
incluso de la pertenencia al a la propia
otan esto es una visión geopolítica en
la cual el intento ruso de gravitar
sobre Bielorrusia y sobre Ucrania habría
sido habría ocurrido inexorablemente
dicen que es un escenario que era
imposible evitar hablemos Fernando de
hoy en día la situación y lo que ha
significado para la otan este año de
Invasión hay muchos analistas que dicen
que este este conflicto y esta invasión
desatada hace prácticamente un año en la
región del Don vas revitalizó esta
Alianza internacional después de
escenarios como Afganistán como la
guerra en Siria y también pues el mismo
conflicto en en Irak en su momento es
así en que se revitalizó la
Alianza atlántica en en términos de una
desprestigiada imagen internacional muy
criticada también por muchos organismos
a nivel internacional o la revitalizó
como una estructura militar mucho más
sólida como la ve usted a ver el
problema central de la otan Es que
particularmente desde la creación de la
Unión Europea desde los tratados de
Matrix y sobre todo el fracaso de los
plebiscitos que aprobaron la
rechazaron y congelaron la Constitución
europea la otan se convirtió en una
suerte de convidado de piedra una suerte
de elefante en la habitación que
representaba la llegada o el poder de
los Estados Unidos en
una Europa que tras la Guerra Fría se
consideraba a sí misma recuperando
grados considerables de poder además la
desaparición de La amenaza soviética
llevó a que la otan te re perfilara como
una forma o una estructura de occidente
de West como lo denominan más bien los
anglosajones para relacionarse con el
mundo particularmente tras los atentados
a las Torres Gemelas bueno durante la
década feliz entre comillas entre el 91
y los atentados los Torres gemelas que
usó para organizar misiones de paz
procesos de construcción de estado
construcción de nación la famosa y
fallida operación en sommelia restaurant
es el gran símbolo de esta acción sin
embargo hoy día recupera su función
trágicamente porque nuevamente nos
construye una barrera cultural que
separa a Rusia de Europa la vuelve a
perfilar como una amenaza y genera una
lo que Huntington denominó en su momento
como los conflictos de fractura es decir
una estructura de separación o de
división estratégica en la cual se
genera un problema mayor Perdón
Catalina su opinión sobre esta
revitalización de la otan Yo creo que es
cierto y creo que es cierto porque la
otan y sobre todo hoy en día no solo
puede ser entendida como una institución
militar sino también política y en esas
en esas intenciones políticas también ha
generado consensos que no se habían
podido generar antes frente amenazas que
no parecían tan comunes a toda la Unión
Europea o a todos los países mejor que
hacen parte de la otan y también ha
permitido no solo dar cierta asistencia
militar muy importante Ucrania sino que
también ha permitido
tecnificar aún más y actualizar el
armamento militar de los mismos países
de la otan y también ha permitido que
este conflicto nucrania permita que la
otan y los países de la otan observen
con mayor contundencia conflictos en
otras partes del mundo que alguna otra
forma ya se están empezando a relacionar
con lo que está pasando en Ucrania por
ejemplo el temor del avanzado el
crecimiento nuclear bélico de Irán eso
también es es un tema importante o el
conflicto en el mar del sur de china con
Estados Unidos y China esto creo que si
bien no es un tema directo de la otan ha
permitido que la otan sí vuelva a
desarrollar capacidades que había
perdido porque había perdido su vigencia
como como dicen mis colegas y sin lugar
a dudas pues Tendremos que qué pasa en
la continuación de este conflicto con
las capacidades que desarrolle tanto los
países de la botas de la otan para sí
mismos como hacia Ucrania sí reinaldo le
doy espacio para que nos cuentes su
opinión sobre este tema y le extiendo la
pregunta preguntándoles justamente por
ese ese escenario político que está
planteando Catalina que sea politizado
en ciertos escenarios Y eso lo vemos en
la posición que ha tenido Turquía para
el ingreso de Suecia y Finlandia a la a
la otan que tiene que ser por consenso
todos los países tienen que estar de
acuerdo en su incorporación y Turquía en
cierta forma se volvió una piedra en el
zapato sobre todo para el caso sueco
Finlandia ya está adelante y Está
avanzando en su incorporación pero aquí
Turquía mezcló un tema propio de las
relaciones tocó el modo ancara en una
membresía de una de una alianza
internacional cómo lo ve usted
Bueno ahí hay una serie de intereses por
parte del Estado Turco para tener esa
esa posición pero yo volvería al tema de
la importancia que que tiene ahora la
otan y sobre todo en términos de la
alianza entre Europa y Estados Unidos es
decir una organización
principalmente no solamente es militar
Pero principalmente militar en este
momento que
que lleva adelante lo que ellos
consideran la defensa del espacio
europeo y su involucramiento en una
guerra
para la defensa del territorio ucraniano
que es fundamental es decir sin ese
involucramiento de la de la otan y de
los países
es particular Estados Unidos
Alemania
en Gran Bretaña sería muy difícil o
imposible en la resistencia de los
ucranianos
Entonces definitivamente este es un
cambio significativo y muy negativo para
la seguridad rusa que eso es ha sido una
de las de las consecuencias
evidentemente No buscadas pero
conseguidas en este caso por la invasión
a Ucrania es decir una una situación de
inseguridad se ha incrementado aún más y
se ha incrementado hasta el grado de que
un país era neutral como podría ser
Finlandia Pues ahora es parte de la otan
y hay una expansión
continua de de la organización del
Atlántico Norte reina sí continuó con
usted para que tratemos el tema de
Finlandia es muy particular porque como
lo decía Fernando es un país que
perteneció históricamente durante un
periodo de tiempo al imperio ruso tiene
una historia en común con este país
tiene una frontera extensísima 1200
kilómetros en donde Ahora sí la otan va
a estar puerta a puerta con Rusia porque
el tratamiento con Finlandia
Aparentemente
ahora el kremlin ha sido bastante
tranquilo y calmado con esa
incorporación de Finlandia no lo ve como
una amenaza tener esta frontera tan
grande y tener el despliegue militar que
pueda haber de la otan allí
bueno en general la expansión de la otan
para Rusia se ve como una amenaza y
además no solo como una amenaza sino
como una justificación a la insistencia
y que necesitan un espacio en donde no
esté la otan y que no esté en las
fronteras este con Rusia no
O sea fortalece más ese argumento y ahí
Quizá el otro actor que entra en la
arena y que es muy importante es China
si uno analiza los doce puntos de China
Que obviamente son aceptados por por la
otra en este momento
insisten en que está continua expansión
de la otan significa un problema para la
seguridad internacional entonces hay más
actores internacionales en este momento
y ya no es simplemente un problema
europeo sino que se está viendo como una
guerra que está implicando a las
principales potencias del planeta Y en
vez haya una desescalada del conflicto
lo que se ve es que esto se está
prolongando están aumentando las
tensiones y aumentando los conflictos
parece están abriendo otros puntos de
tensión como el que mencionaba Catalina
aquí en el estudio en el mar del sur de
China Catalina su opinión sobre este
corporación de Finlandia Qué significa
es importante para la otra en tener esta
esta frontera de estar puerta a Puerta
prácticamente con la con Rusia Sí yo
creo que supremamente importante también
porque muestra la vigencia de la otan
en la actualidad pero también en este
conflicto ahora lo que pasa con Turquía
es que hasta donde entiendo el conflicto
entre estocolmo y ankara es por el apoyo
que supuestamente ha dado el gobierno
finlandés o algunos algunos perdón
suecos O finlandeses suecos a kurdistán
y esto insisto es un problema que
seguramente afecta muchos países de la
región de Turquía pero no afectan
necesariamente a la Unión Europea y a
los países de la otan esto hablando del
conflicto en kurdistán en Turquía
y por eso hay una cierta diferencia
diplomática entre ambos países pero yo
genuinamente creo que el conflicto de
Ucrania tiene repercusiones mucho más
genuinas y violentas porque no hacia
Europa occidental y que seguramente
muchos países de Europa occidental
tendrán que ejercer algún lobio presión
política tanto en ankara como en
estocolmo para que en efecto Turquía
permita que este país sea parte de la
otan insisto porque siento que es más
del interés común que la otan se
extienda en un en un momento donde la
guerra está las aportas del continente
de Europa occidental o en la parte
occidental de Europa que el mismo
conflicto que tiene Turquía con
kurdistán creería yo claro y justamente
este escenario ha llevado que algunos
sectores políticos en Turquía ahora que
están en plena campaña presidencial ha
llevado que algunos sectores sobre todo
de la izquierda plantean la posibilidad
de retirar a Turquía de la otan porque
no le ven ven el beneficio y también
porque se presentan estos aquellos que
van en contra de sus intereses políticos
Fernando para cerrar este tema de
Finlandia y la incorporación de estos
países algo más para Añadir para pasar a
hablar ahora de La retórica nuclear de
Rusia adelante Fernanda
en primer lugar la la incorporación de
Finlandia es de alguna manera el final
del orden político posterior a la
Segunda Guerra Mundial en términos de
que tanto Finlandia como Austria fueron
de alguna manera congelados en como
buffer States o como estado separadores
en los cuales ambos estados y en este
caso Finlandia aceptaron la neutralidad
permanente y el no alineamiento como
garantía de seguridad Cuando Finlandia
llama directamente a la integración y la
mayor parte de la población finlandesa
está de acuerdo con ello representa para
ellos un cambio geopolítico de primera
magnitud geoestratégico y también
un avance Celeste que comienza a
configurar lo que algunos autores ya
están definiendo como una
de estados eslavos que se extiende desde
el cabo Norte digamos Noruega Finlandia
hasta precisamente el Mar el mar Negro Y
eso marca una un problema para Rusia que
en buena medida podría plantear que
incluso si obtuvieran una muy improbable
Victoria militar en frente de Ucrania
quedarían ya en una condición
marcadamente complicada respecto a que
no consiguieron a que su situación
geopolítica quedó mucho peor que el
inicio porque frente al temor de que
Ucrania entrara a la otan Bueno ahora
consiguieron que otros dos socios mucho
más relevantes lo hicieran y amenazaran
su posición en el Báltico mucho más
cercanos al propio San Petersburgo de lo
que representa como amenaza Ucrania
Fernando en ese orden
adelante adelante terminé la idea no no
era claro no sobre La retórica nuclear
como mi pregunta Entonces si quiere le
hago la pregunta para que vea el enfoque
es
esta retórica y esta constante amenaza
que hay por parte del kremlin de
recordar su poderío en nuclear de
recordar la capacidad que tiene a nivel
nuclear y los hechos recientes que ese
se despliegue de alguna de algo de
armamento nuclear en territorio de
belarus esto cómo puede ser tomado por
parte de la otan Y qué puede ser más
peligroso la expansión territorial de
Rusia o esa amenaza constante de poderío
nuclear
a ver el uso de armas nucleares es un
tema espinoso por derecho propio que ya
desde la edad de los 70 está claro que
es una herramienta esencialmente de
seguridad de protección es algo que le
permite un estado disuadir el ataque y
así lo ha demostrado la búsqueda por
ejemplo por Corea del Norte o más
recientemente por Irán también en su
momento pakistan India también es un
instrumento de estatus pero ya desde la
década del 70 cuando Nixon trató de
jugar en la negociación de los tratados
Salt con con entonces Unión soviética
claro la opción de un ataque unilateral
digamos por parte de Estados Unidos
sobre Rusia Rusia no lo creyó desde ese
momento en adelante el tabú de ser el
primer usuario de un arma nuclear
es claramente mucho más contundente que
cualquier beneficio militar que pudiera
tratar de conseguirse me atrevería a
decir que es más bien una señal de
debilidad el fracaso completamente
inesperado de las capacidades militares
convencionales rusas solo
la necesidad desesperada de volcarse al
recuerden tengo armas nucleares pero es
reitero más bien una demostración de
debilidad que una demostración de
fortaleza reinaldo en Ciudad de México
su opinión muy puntual por favor que
vamos llegando ya al bloque final del
programa Sí bueno sin duda Sí es una una
muestra de la debilidad rusa pero
justamente eso es lo que se quiere
evitar es decir tú no quieres
acorralada a la otra parte hasta el
momento que se sienta amenazado en su
seguridad
y eso es lo que lo que está pasando con
con la expansión es decir
conforme se expande más la otan Rusia se
siente más insegura y necesita más
condiciones para
detener la guerra
y eso Bueno pues es contraproducente a
lo que se está buscando Claro que en
buena medida es lo que está diciendo
china este
a ver nosotros queremos que haya
seguridad internacional y que se
respeten las fronteras etcétera etcétera
Pero para eso
la parte occidental también tiene que
entender
que no se puede expandir de manera
ilimitada Claro sin que haya
consecuencias El problema es que está
viendo consecuencias así muy graves
sobre todo pues quienes están sufriendo
más son los ucranianos y más grave más
grave Aún reinaldo es ver esas
consecuencias y entendiendo ese mensaje
del kremlin diciendo que está preparado
para un conflicto de larga duración lo
que tenga que durar este conflicto lo
pueden mantener abierto para cerrar esta
ronda Catalina algo para decir si yo lo
primero que voy a decir es que estoy
absolutamente de acuerdo con mis colegas
en chile y en México quiero Añadir dos
cosas más la primera es que
esto Esto no es nuevo para el
comportamiento de China de perdón de
Rusia o lo que fue en su momento La
Unión soviética
El problema es que el contexto
internacional ha cambiado estamos en un
sistema internacional que es multipolar
china acá juega un papel fundamental
china en su contrapropuesta a la
resolución de la asamblea general de la
ONU del 23 de febrero dio como uno de
sus puntos a no acceder que el uso de
armas nucleares Simplemente no iba a
suceder y la palabra de China incluso
puede llegar a ser más contundente que
la misma intención rusa Entonces yo
insisto creo que también es una muestra
debilidad y creo que hay otros actores
importantes que juegan ahí
un rol decisorio en lo que quiera o no
hace Rusia frente a las armas nucleares
creo también que hay otros actores que
están en desacuerdo con que este suceda
aunque no han tenido un rol protagónico
en el conflicto tenemos por ejemplo al
bloque africano al bloque de América
Latina o al bloque al bloque del sudeste
asiático Quienes se han pronunciado muy
poco sobre este conflicto pero que sin
lugar a dudas dirán en escenarios de la
asamblea general de la ONU por ejemplo
que el uso de armas nucleares no solo
afecta al continente europeo que es el
corazón de este conflicto sino afectar
absolutamente todos los actores
involucrados del mundo entero y del
sistema internacional Esas son las dos
cosas que yo añadiría me queda unos
minutos para hacer la última pregunta y
se la voy a dirigir a reinaldo porque él
mencionó estos actores internacionales
también fue el que introdujo el tema el
actor de china en en este conflicto y
creo que esto va en línea con lo que
está diciendo Rusia en este momento Y es
que acusa la otan de querer formar un
eje mundial Precisamente hay muchos
analistas que también han dicho que se
quiere llevar este escenario de guerra a
este escenario del Pacífico y vemos esas
alianzas que está gestando Estados
Unidos con Australia con Japón con Corea
como analiza usted lo de esta este
enunciado de un eje mundial muy puntual
por favor porque me quedan pocos minutos
sí desafortunadamente lo que parece es
que hay claramente una una intención de
volver a una política de contención por
parte de Estados Unidos
y y la y la guerra Alemania pues ha
acelerado todo este proceso ya no es
solo una política de contención Rusia
sino también es una política de
contención China y Y pues sí hay hay Esa
esa es una consecuencia otra vez no
buscada por parte de lo que lo que está
ocurriendo en la guerra en Ucrania me
quedan un par de minutos para finalizar
el programa Fernando quiero que hagamos
conclusiones Catalina reinaldo hagamos
las conclusiones si Fernando tiene algo
para Añadir sobre este tema del eje
mundial aproveché y y lo dice en este
momento y las conclusiones lo que viene
para esta Alianza lo que viene para este
conflicto
no la otan se ha revalidado claramente y
además ha adquirido un tono netamente
anglosajón debido a las dudas alemanas
ha despejado un escenario en el cual los
nueve de bucarest todo el este de Europa
se siente mucho más segura
relacionándose estratégicamente con
Estados Unidos y con
Gran Bretaña eso también va a tener
consecuencias gigantescas porque hay un
cambio de eje en términos de
geoestratégicos en el propio continente
europeo se ve muy difícil que la Unión
Europea pueda construir una alternativa
estratégica después de esta situación
Catalina su conclusión Sí yo también
estoy de acuerdo la otan se fortaleció
con este conflicto Seguramente se
seguirá fortaleciendo en cuanto a este
gran bloque hegemónico de occidente Pues
creo que también hay que darle la
libertad a los pueblos de autoproclamar
sus intenciones y creo que esto se
demostró con los 141 votos a favor de la
resolución es de la asamblea general de
la ONU sobre el caso ucraniano entonces
creo que es retórica
y dialéctica rusa que desconoce un poco
intencionalmente lo que los otros
pueblos deciden hacer por ejemplo en
América Latina África del sudeste
asiático eso sería lo que tendría que
concluir yo y reinaldo su conclusión
para el cierre sí sin duda la otan y
Estados Unidos
pero Desafortunadamente la seguridad en
el mundo no se ha fortalecido y eso es
una de las cosas más peligrosas es decir
el que tengamos cada vez más tensiones
estratégicas y militares en un mundo
distinto en un mundo multipolar Pues nos
hace ver que este mundo multipolar es
mucho más inseguro que la anterior Pues
a Catalina Fernando y a reinaldo les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros El tiempo pasa volando se nos
caen algunos temas sobre la mesa pero
hicimos un análisis de lo que ha
significado para la otan Este primer año
de invasión de Rusia a Ucrania ustedes
Muchas gracias por la sintonía y el
nombre del equipo también Les
agradecemos haber estado con nosotros la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Laura garzón y Giovanni agudelo y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera Pueden seguir dejando
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales Siguen con
nosotros
[Música]